I'm going to tell you a little bit about
the so called Riemann hypothesis and the
subtitle of the talk is how to make
million bucks
without getting out of it so let me
explain why that's the subtitle it's
going reverse order so why don't you
need to get outta bed to study this
problem in the other sciences physics
chemistry biology all you need to do is
observe the physical world the real
world that we live in I need to say you
know whatever it is that you're studying
you will want to make your objects
observe the world and make a
mathematical model a sort of let's boil
everything down to the bare essentials
so it's a very crude approximation
what's really going on you solve the
model and once you do that you hope that
it's going to predict real-life behavior
so here's a very important example of
physics in action you need to make sure
that the Angry Bird will not get paying
over and then tumble the whole castle
okay so this is how physics would
approach the problem on mathematics on
the other hand of course you're
influenced by the outside world but you
don't need anything other than your mind
to think about numbers and concepts
coming out of mathematics we're just the
same halfway around the world in India
or China or on the moon as far as we
know any two plus two is still four when
you get to the Moon or Mars or in your
bed so that's the reason that you can do
this you can think about this problem
without going anywhere of course it
helps maybe to go to finish high school
college grad school and so on one of the
drawbacks is if we're just playing games
in our mind we have to completely
convince ourselves as we know what's
going on with Angry Birds if you tell me
shoot at 45-degree angles and I swear
it's going to hit the pig well all I
have to do is actually
shooting and then we know what it was
right and in that we're going to have a
party approved in other word for proof
is arguments so you have to have a
completely sound explanation for why you
think what's going on is really what's
going on all right let me tell you about
this the second part of the sentence
million dollar prize so in the year
nineteen hundred to one hundred and
twelve years ago there was a big famous
meeting international meeting
mathematicians from all over the world
came together and one of the most famous
Indian mathematicians the guy needed
David Hilbert there is with a hat and
what he suggested is he proposed fuse
the problems that were around at least
some of them but he sort of collected
them into here are the most important
problems there are 23 events 23 years
and most important problems for
mathematics that tackle in the next
hundred years here are the problems for
the 20th century and number eight on his
list
our Riemann hypothesis fast forward a
hundred years the year 2000 not so long
ago some of you were born men by then
there's a new clay mask Institute that
was just founded a year before and it
was based at Harvard now a photographer
and they posed not 23 but seven problems
seven problems for the Millennium the
Millennium problems prize problems not
only that they posed them again these
are problems that were well-known they
didn't close them they just collected
them and said these are the most
important they put a million dollar
bounty on each problem you solve even
one of these problems they will give you
a million dollars in cash and number
four on their list is the Riemann
hypothesis in fact it's the only problem
which appears both on the most wanted
list in 1900 and the most wanted list in
2000 so this thing is really one of the
most important problems in all of
mathematics in case you get so
discouraged ah there's not a chance
you know there's no way I'm going to be
able to solve this thing people have
been thinking about it for 150 years
number three on this list on the claim
at least a two million dollar list is
the so-called Padre conjecture which we
will not discuss today you may have
heard you may watch Matt news probably
you don't three years after this problem
made its most-wanted list
the millennium most wanted list a guy
named Herbert Pearlman solved the Padre
conjecture
so it's not impossible for these
absolutely unbelievable problems to get
solved I should say he had been working
on it much longer than the three years
between when it became a prize problem
and when he solved it and it's based on
100 years of worth of mathematics and I
should also tell you that when they gave
him the million dollars he said thanks
but no thanks
and that's him kicking the million bucks
away the proof was enough for him just
the satisfaction of having proved this
thing was all he wanted so the champion
is okay this problems hard
if you solve it fantastic you'll be
world famous but if there's a tradition
of not taking a million you might have
some freshman laughing go take it anyway
million bucks why not
all right so what is the Riemann
hypothesis well it was stated in 1859
over 150 years ago
Buckhorn I'm reading there is again and
it's seen hundreds if not thousands of
false proof people that write papers
even publish papers circulate papers
professional mathematicians amateurs
experts in the field have given false
arguments arguments then when they show
someone else they said wait a second how
do you get from this line to this line a
miracle occurs well that's not an
explanation so there it's seen hundreds
of false proofs and whatever it is I'll
try to explain what it is numerically
it's been verified a billion times it's
really predicting what's supposed to
happen we just don't know why
okay so let's not beat around the bush
what is what is the Riemann hypothesis
does it's complicated if it wasn't
complicated it wouldn't be such a high
problem but I'll give you the one
sentence version it's that Riemann was
the first human being to hear the music
of the primes and my hope is today you
will - all right so the Riemann
hypothesis is a problem without prime
numbers so let's talk for a second about
prime numbers just to get a warm-up what
are the divisors of six what are the
whole numbers that evenly divides it
please search one two and three our
devices will also count six so six is
gets on any number divides itself evenly
any whole number that divides evenly is
called the divisor thank you very much
that's a perfect answer one two three
and six are the divisors of six now what
is a prime number yes
perfect and so it has exactly two
devices because it can only be divided
by one and it can be divided by itself
and no other no yes sir
excellent question at the time the
Riemann hypothesis was posed one was no
longer considered a prime number but for
a long long time before then one was
considered a prime number so today for
very many reasons we do not consider one
a prime number so one does not count and
that's exactly why I say exactly two
divisors one is only one divisor it's up
okay excellent question
so you probably have seen the primes
here's a short list of some of them 2 3
5 7 11 you can read I'm sorry - is not a
prime - gives the oddest proc absolutely
absolutely yeah
- is a that's yeah absolutely - is the
weirdest of all the primes it's the only
even one it is a lot of very strange
properties but but it is a pride whereas
one we will not consider a prime at
least today why are these things
important why do we care about prime
numbers at all what makes them any
different from six the primes are the
building blocks of all numbers if you
take any number you can decompose it
into primes if it's already prime and in
that way they are like the elementary
particles and physics the in
decomposable pieces of matter and our
universe that make up everything that we
know so any number that we know of can
be decomposed into primes and that's why
the crimes are so important to the
fundamental building book so you can
think of - is an electron trees the
lepton or photon 101 dalmatians for some
reason or expose on if you
know when these things are okay now
there are in the standard model there
are twelve fundamental particles and
that can change from time to time so
this is another reason why mathematics
is different from Sciences that observe
the world Newton knew exactly how
physics works until Einstein changed it
and now Einstein knew exactly how
physics works until quantum mechanics
changed it and and so on so these things
change with time crimes except for one
one changes whether we consider one a
prime or not change history time but
that's just a definition that's just a
work the facts about numbers do not
change throughout absolutely University
so there are twelve fundamental
particles how many Prime's are they how
many people think there are twenty
condos
raising more than twenty that's right
you should be upset
how about thirty or a hundred or a
thousand or a million
how many cries you think there let me
pick up some we all we all know the
answer right infinite right there have
to be right because we can make a
computer program and just keep looking
for them as far out as we want that's
not a crew that's an observation that's
not a proof you know rigorous argument
we need a very when you vary it's not
something that you just oh it has to be
you can just throw your hands up in the
air that's not a mathematical proof
so today we'll prove a theorem our first
airing of the day it are in fact
infinitely many prime numbers the proof
that we're going to present there are
many many proofs of this fact but the
earliest proof that we know of is by an
ancient Greek mathematician named you
click lived in Alexandria modern Egypt
and it was given two thousand three
hundred years ago pretty amazing the
first thing we need to know to present
Euclid's proof is what does it need not
to be prime so a number is composite if
it's not prime what does it mean for a
number to be composite how do we tell
that
is composite well like you said we just
checked it some other number divides it
and it's enough to check it some prime
divides it even so a number is evenly
divisible if it leaves a remainder is
zero so here's we're going to check it
seventy-five is a prime or not well we
try to divide it by two that leaves a
remainder of one
so that doesn't that doesn't tell you
anything but if you divided by three it
leaves a remainder of zero and so the
number has a remainder zero when divided
by some prime then it's not crying
then it's composite right that's all we
need to know for this group so how did
the proof go it goes by contradiction
let's say I'm wrong let's say we're all
wrong and there are only finitely many
Prime's okay if we can find a
contradiction to this assumption we'll
just follow very logically from this
assumption and come to something that
just doesn't make any sense
then this assumption must be wrong and
there have to be implemented crimes so
this is what's called a proof by
contradiction so let's assume for now
suspend your disbelief let's assume that
there are only finitely many prime
numbers let's list all of them there's
only five we made 2 3 5 7 11 13 to vote
on and on 100 million a billion of
Julian a googolplex however many there
are there's some largest number which is
prime which is capital P so now we have
this list of every prime number in the
universe and it's a finite list because
we assumed it is take this number
capital n where you multiply all the
primes by each other so 2 times 3 times
5 times 7 all the way up to this
hypothetical largest prime ever capital
P you multiply all these together it's a
finite product of finite numbers
if some is just someone integer take
this integer and add one too
okay so n is the product of all prime
numbers with one more attack on the end
so let's test whether or not and can be
prime well or or let's test if it can be
composite so if you take N and you
divide it by two well this piece is
divisible by two so what remainder is at
least one if you take any divided by
three
it leaves a remainder of one if you take
n divided by 57 not prime 59 it leaves
remainder one right so any prime number
since all the prime numbers are here
when you divide n by any prime number at
all it leaves a remainder of one and one
last I checked is not zero and so this
number can't be composite because if it
lifts a remainder of zero when divided
by some prime number that's what it
would mean to be composite so that means
in there's big number end of your
account is not a composite number but
what does that mean by definition it's
not composites and it's and it's a crime
right what's the problem with that
anybody else already picked on you yes
back then perfect P is the highest prime
number and yet we just show that there's
another number which is crying which is
bigger than P so n is not this number n
is not in our list of all prime numbers
P is supposed to be the largest and
that's a contradiction and now we need
to write these three funny letters
quitter at them in Stratham therefore we
have proved what we set up anybody so if
you observe we didn't actually sit at a
computer and write down even a single
prime number for this proof it's a proof
by pure thumb
it's just an argument it's just a
discussion between you and me I think
everyone in this room is now convinced
it can't be the case that they're
finding too many prime numbers to have
to be okay any questions all right
well once you ask about the friends
themselves you might be interested in
patterns of prize mathematicians life
patterns and like finding pattern so
anybody know what a twin crime is yes
right there
it's two primes that are two away from
each other numbers P and P plus two
which are both prime numbers so let's
just look at that list at table that we
had so three and five give four by two
and they're both prime numbers five and
seven differ by 2 11 and 13 different by
two 41 and 43 different by two and this
is the sequence of the first few pairs
of three prime numbers what's the most
natural question we would ask when we
see a list like this how many how many
right are there 10 30 a million are
their implementing twin primes again you
write a computer program and ask it to
give you lists it gives you lists for as
long as you like but that's not a proof
that's not a rigorous argument that
tells you what the answer has to be and
always will be forever so what's the
answer
anybody know
you're right that's the correct answer
the correct answer is nobody knows 2300
years after Euclid's proof that they're
implementing crimes
the very next most natural question you
could ask patterns of twin crimes we
still do not know the answer we don't
know the answer rigorously we think we
know the answer we think it's yes
why shouldn't there be but that's not a
proof mathematics requires nothing but
absolute proof is that clear
all right and no one has given one for
this problem here's a little homework
assignment for you why can't you use the
argument we just gave we just gave
Euclid's argument that there have to be
many primes try to adapt that argument
to this problem what goes wrong think
about it you don't have to give me an
answer now that's a home all right
here's another pattern of crimes that
people like these are called marsan
crimes anybody know anybody heard of
Marsan crimes but you know what a Marsan
crime is okay okay these also make the
math news sometimes from again probably
not here Sunday morning reading it's
named after this guy very marsan he was
studying them in the late 15th early mid
1600s a Mersenne prime is a prime number
which is almost a perfect power of two
so the power of the two one two four
eight 16 32 and so on and we're set
prime is a prime number which is just
one less than a power of two so let's
just see 2 to the 2 to the 1 is 2 and if
we subtract one off of that we get 1 in
more sense time one was a private for us
1 is not a friend how about 2 squared 4
minus 1 3 3 is prime that's a Mersenne
prime that's our first percent prime 2
to the third is 8 minus 1 7 is prime 2
to the 4 16 minus 1
15 is 3 times 5 now from ok we can keep
playing this game forever 32 minus one
is 31 this list is much more sparse than
the last one but here's a number anybody
know what suited of 4 I can be 43
million 100 and whatever minus 1 I'm not
going to write it out if it's 10 million
digits long but this number is the
largest marsan crime we know of today
question
oh no justice justice character sketches
are a lot of two of course what's the
natural question are there incrementing
what do you think we know about this
nothing okay let me tell you a little
anecdote there's a very famous lecture
by a guy named Frank Nelson Cole there
he is there in 1903
110 years ago what he did is imagine if
I did this to you
he spent an hour his entire hour lecture
he spent computing in utter silence on
the blackboard just computing what was
he computing something very complicated
no well that's something a little
complicated but it's nothing that you
can do on your own with thousand hours
of paper and pen if you're tooted to ^
67
well subtracting one even I can do but
this is 2 to the 67 with an eighth day
that's a huge number and a huge
computation it took them about a half
hour to get all of the numbers down and
do the long you know you have to
multiply down in a clever way huh just
the most trivial way and he gets that
number that takes a half hour on the
other half of the blackboard he writes
down that number 103 million and so on
and you write sounds that number 700
billion and he stands there and in front
of a room full room like this of
professional mathematicians not a
theater it multiplies this out and as
he's nearing
and you're hearing losing us as people
realize that he has factored to to the
67 minus one which is not a Mersenne
prime because it's not a primer okay so
okay on the computer today you do this
in a second but I hope you appreciate
the magnitude of difficulty of this
problem and that we really don't know
very much about Mersenne primes and much
in the same way when you get to very
large prime numbers twin primes are good
so let's get back to the Riemann
hypothesis does the problem we're trying
to understand today what's the moral of
the examples we just discussed prime
numbers are very mysterious and we know
very little about them now the Riemann
hypothesis says two things about it
number one it says that the prime
numbers are beautifully structured they
have an amazing structure and number two
is that prime numbers are completely
random if it sounds like those two
things are in direct contradiction with
each other you'll see what I mean so I
have to explain exactly what these
statements are so let's start with
number two let me try to explain to you
why Prime's a random okay here's a guy
maybe you've heard of him Mobius he's
named after his strip the other way and
what he did is he gave a spin to numbers
so one has spin up it's one it's got an
F spin out two has spin down three has
spin down what do you think for the spin
of four is how many people say up how
many people say down well it's as no
spin
you didn't know there was an option seat
how about five spin up or down down how
about six oh how about seven down eight
go spin nine no spin 10 is out here the
next 10 what's the pattern yeah what's
the connection
alright let me pick on you again what
about 9 12 is not a square it has no
spin it's an excellent guess oh yeah oh
yes so there are four rules rule one is
that one has spin up rule 2 is that any
prime number has been down what's really
it's almost what you said whatever a
number has a square divisor whenever
there are two prime factors of the same
prime in the number like 4 which has
some twos in it not 8 and 9 have are
divisible by squares 12 is divisible by
4 which is a square those spins cancel
out and that number has no spin and what
about a number that's a product of
distinct prime factors well each prime
factor contributes a down spin and 2
down students cancel out coming up spit
ok so let's just see if we understood
with that what that means let's compute
the spin of 30 so what do we need to
know to compute a spin of something we
need its prime factorization so what's
the prime factorization
what's the prime factorization of 30
pretend you're deaf yeah 2:35 good so
what's its pink to gives it a spin down
three gives it a spin down five gives it
a spin down three down spins is the same
as one down spin in just the two two
down spins gets loud so 30 has spin 10
okay that's Mobius funny now it's nicer
to think of instead of arrows numbers so
let's just convert an up arrow into a
plus one a down arrow to minus one and
no spin is Europe okay so here's mo
business function again if some squared
divides the number n then you get 0 if n
is a product of an odd number of
distinct crimes then there's one spin
that's not matched up and if n is a
product of an even number of prime
factorize then it has spin plus 1 just
as we just say so let me just put the
table there again so here's the first
line is just the numbers the second line
is their spin as we just saw in the
third line is the möbius function which
converts arrows to numbers any questions
now what are the partial sums of the
möbius function so what do I mean by
partial sums you pick some number X and
you add up the first X spin
let me explain with that name so let's
start with X at most 10 so we start here
at 0 when we get to 1 1 head spin plus 1
so we take a step up and when we hit the
2 to it spin down it has Moebius minus 1
so we go down what happens 3 go now what
happens at for nothing we just stay
where we are but m25 down six up seven
down eight and nine we don't do anything
can we go up you see what's going on
let's go out to 20 so the first 10 is
exactly what we just saw and then 11
goes down 12 doesn't do anyth
13 goes down 14 goes up and so on okay
you do it out to 100 and you do it out
to a thousand I can do it out to 20,000
isn't that weird yes it is weird thank
you this is what we mean by Prime's are
random now I have to explain what that
means so let me explain what I mean by a
number being random well what does it
need to be random say I have a three
sided coin I don't know how you get a
three sided coin but suppose it flips
with probability of 13 lands up probably
230 lands down probably a third atlantes
I don't know on its side or something if
we were to add up these partial spins
out to 20,000 here's one sample picture
now in probability theory there's a very
famous theorem called the central limit
theorem I'm not going to prove before
you today but basically what it says is
you should compare a curve like this to
the graph y equals root X plus your mind
so there's this it's a parabola Y
squared equals x so it's just the
parabola but it's on its side and what
you should be seeing what this theorem
says is this hat should stay inside the
curve it's allowed to touch the curve
it's even allowed to go a little bit
outside the curve because it's very
formal mathematical that sounds like I
wish you watching James before
mathematical statement which I own it
tell you because it's complicated but at
the essence of what it says you should
compare this curve to the curve brunet
and it should stay inside this bag let's
see what's going on with Mobius monkey
so let me put these Mobius tones that we
saw there it is
can you even tell which path is which
anymore yes some yes some no it's hard
to tell the Riemann hypothesis says you
can't tell it looks random all right
let's just test this out anybody got a
coin
raise your hand if you have access to
something you can flip it there are
three of you with coins in here
ask your mom okay raise your hand if
ever anybody who's got a point if you
have more than one coin you can give it
to your game we're gonna play I hope
they give it back to you okay yeah
points whoever has a coin keep your hand
up now we're talking all right here's
what we're going to do we're all going
to flip our point okay you flip you
catch and you see what you have
all right everybody flip now once you
know what you have either heads they
just hold your hand up in the air you're
going to tell me one at a time what you
have we're going to go around Rome
you're gonna tell me what you have okay
ready
wait a second don't tell me it not
listening okay I had a head who's got a
hand up please Hey keep going as fast as
you can heads tails kale kale and so
just keep it up just going down hey hey
hey hey I heard that I hear the tail
head to the tail tail tail tail tail
good tail tail and that may be a mistake
it no you're going tail tail head head
tail head hey hey
tail-head mic window two in the back
what do you got
hey over there tail
alright that's that's your beam up let's
see if this works
that's our graph this is the sequence of
heads and tails that you just yelled out
at me and as you see look at it we had
about 40 people call things out if every
single one of you had a head this crap
would just go straight up to 40 the
square root of 40 is like 36 is the
square root of 36 is about 6 and this is
6 and here's give or take 6 and look at
our rep obviously I couldn't break this
that's what the central limit theorem
says and what the Riemann hypothesis
says is that the sums of the möbius
function behave in exactly the same
let's go back let me try to explain to
you a little better ok here we go
alright let's look at another version of
it there's another reversion well for
that we need to remember log so what's
log not that it's the logarithm function
y equals log of X so if you don't know
what this is you don't really need to
know if the inverse function is e to the
X 1 you don't need know what that is let
me just remind you that E is a number
between 2 & 3
it's called II after Euler although it
was known long before him here's a graph
of 2 to the X and a graph of 3 to the X
and E is between 2 & 3 so there's the
curve that sits inside and what does it
mean to be the inverse it means if we
draw a to the X and we flip everything
along the line y it was exit
place the role of x and y we get this
curve y equals logging okay if you
haven't seen this before it doesn't
really matter it's just some function
gives you some number its value at 1 is
0
and there's another property of it W so
let me tell you what the fun Mangold
funky I looked all over Google Images I
couldn't find a picture of on mango so
here's what it gives you for the number
one it gives the value 0 but the number
2 it gives the value log of 2 which is
like 0.69 for number 3 is the value log
of 3 what do you think is in all your
fur for log 7 is it interesting yes log
4 is a better guest it's log of 2 how
about 5 5 okay how about 6
zero you do I'm up Oh clicked you soon
okay what's it gonna be log it - good
how about 9 rocket 3 you guys how about
10 zero
so just I'm just writing out the numbers
so you see log of 3 is just 1 point 1
log of 7 is 1 point 9 what's the pattern
yes sir close it's sort of what you said
you get log of a number if the number is
an exact power of a prime so for example
8 is 2 cubed so it's a power of the
prime - and that's why you get a log of
2 + 9 is 3 squares and that's why I see
a log of 3 and 5 is 5 to the 1 which is
why you see log of up and what about
numbers that aren't powers of crimes
just put a 0 6 there's about two
different crimes 0 n is 2 times 5 you
put it here ok let's look at the partial
sums of this long mangle function here
they are again let's let's graph them
out to 10 so what does this say we start
at the origin we get to 1 we add 0 so we
don't do anything we get the 2 we add
point 6 9 we get the 3 we had
one point one we had before we add 6v is
a 5 we add 5 we get mistakes we had
nothing we don't move and so on ok so if
this little step function like that
that's the other sums of the home angle
function
how's the 20 it looks like that so again
the first half is what we just saw out
to a hundred it looks like that and out
to a thousand it looks like that what
does that look like it looks just like
the graph of y equals x let me show you
why equals x that weird let's see you
see it's sort of wiggling around the
line y equals x let's see what happens
if you subtract it off y equals x from
that stuff so what do I mean by that
we're going to take these partial sums
and subtract X Aquajet so let's go out
to 10 again here's the graph out the 10
that we just discussed here's the line y
equals x how are we going to take at any
point we're going to take this number
and subtract that number so we get first
at least we'll get negative numbers so
there's the difference that's what
that's the wiggle it working here's that
same wiggle so you see this little
pattern out the 10 we're going to see
that same wiggle pattern out to 10 here
but then we'll keep going out to a
hundred there's the wiggle pattern and
out to a thousand there's a wiggle
pageant what does that look random
he looks random how do we test if it if
it looks random identical extreme
yeah let's test it against this problem
there is the problem well you don't see
it yet but when you go out quite quite a
bit further it's going to start hitting
the boundaries on the problem but it's
supposed to stay more or less inside
supposed to behave just like a random
function okay so let's recap the prizes
are random in two ways we can look at
partial sums on the möbius function that
looks random we can look at partial sums
of the bomb angle function with this X
subtract it up that looks random is
there a relationship between these two
for now
let me try to explain that running low
on time so remember long ago one was
zero and the only other property we need
is if you multiply two numbers and take
their logs the same as adding the values
of the law here are the values of the
von Mangal function which come out as
fings I'm just reminding you here are
the values of the sorry the möbius
function here the values of the bond
angle function and there you know log of
2 is just some number points let's go
back to that our favorite number six
over its divisors one two three and six
let's point by manual function of six on
one side and on the other side let's
take the möbius function and multiply it
by log and evaluate that as the divisor
so we'll put Mobius of 1 log of one
Mobius is 2 log of 2 Mobius if you log
of 3 and Mobius is just log of 6 and
let's add all of these numbers up
ok so what's my angle to 6
use your table of six bond angle sorry
lambda of 6 is zero okay zero how about
Mobius of 1
Oh B sub 1 is +1 but log of 1 is 0
Mobius if 2 is Mobius so whole piece is
known within you and you don't know your
Greek letter o case is the top guy and
okay so Mobius gives you a minus 1 that
block to Mobius of 3 is minus 1 and plug
3 and Mobius of 6 is plus 1 times log of
6 so let's just check here is 0 and here
zero somebody's already got it well I
have 6 by that formula is log of 2 x
plus log of 3 here's a minus log of 2
and a minus log of 3 and what do you get
0 they all cancel out so here's another
homework proof proof give a rigorous
argument get in complete generality if
you take a number in and you write all
of its divisors just like we did D 1 D 2
up to D K and you take the bottom angle
function and you take Mobius at the
divided kind of log of the divisor you
add this up over all the divisors you
will always get to fix it so this is the
relationship between the bond manual
function and the Mobius function they're
very intimately related to one another
through this function log ok let's recap
again the primes are supposed to be
random if you look at partial sums of
Mobius
or if I'm angle minus X they both stay
inside this curve root X and that's what
it means to be random that is the
Riemann house during my process says
primes are random Buttrey month as I
explained saw something much much deeper
and it's that primes are perfectly
structured in fact he heard the music of
the price so that's what I'm going to
try to explain ok so we have to talk a
little bit about music and for that let
me introduce you to a few friends of
mine
this is best rose and May so
this is best this is an alto saxophone
this is not bestest best day I don't
know if you guys can see rundas rubber
bands all over it because one of the
hosts came off this morning let's hope
it's the work that's best this is rose
say hi rose anybody know what that's
called sopran outside right rose see
she's up and running this is rose and
May anybody know what me is clarinet
right music fine sitting around for a
little while okay so we have these three
horns an alto sax a soprano sax and a
clarinet there so the saxophones were
another bag invested by a dog Jackson
mid 50s and I want to present you with
three mysteries about these swamps
so mystery one let's measure the length
of the soprano in the clarinet so if you
see well we have to unwind this is the
soprano is a little wrapped up but if we
unwind it you see they're about the same
length they're almost exactly the same
length these too long this one's one
doesn't start to see that length is
about 26 inches you can even tell here
at 26 27 inches okay how about the alto
the alto is if you were to unwind it
it's 39 to 40 inches and then you would
notice the relationship between 39 and
26 what's the ratio from one to the
other two thirds right or three yet
twenty-six times three halves is so we
can see that by comparing the clarinet
to the sex today also and seeing that
what's left over is about half of the
clarinet one and a half the length of
the clarinet it's the length of the
sexual alright why these lengths why is
this ratio what's so interesting about
three half mysteries too let's study the
lowest notes on each horn so on a sax on
the alto that's the lowest note on our
clarinet
that's the lowest note they're pretty
close right the lowest note ah there is
almost exactly the same note as the
lowest note I don't help to help it just
has one one more half step lower than a
clarinet so the lowest note on may is
almost the same as the lowest note on
best part as opposed to Rose that lowest
note is much higher than the lowest note
on the other guys it's in fact three
halves I'll try to explain what that
means
three halves hi so question - why is
this happening
question three the saxophone sound is
often described as being lyrical and
voiced light and very sort of warm
that's kind of a warm quality to it
whereas the clarinet is often described
as having a very pure sound it's a very
you can tell the timbers are completely
different from a saxophone to a clarinet
so question three is wider than Tambor's
okay so let's summarize our mysteries as
far as life goes the alto sax is the odd
man out
Rosen's the soprano on planet I've got
the same length but if you look at
lowest note the soprano sax is the odd
man out
Sparrow has a much higher lowest note of
any alto for the clarinet and as far as
hammers concerned the two saxes have a
warm sound and the clarinet has a pure
sound clarinets geography so what are
these things happens well to understand
it we have to understand what is sound
so I'm running very low on time let me
try to rush through this sound is a mosh
pit you have a whole bunch of people in
a room they're all dancing and if one of
them is we shove and one guy shows just
shoves in a random direction
everybody nearby starts to fall and
tumble and if you're Lenny of this from
overhead you see regions where people
are squished together in regions where
there is little space so sound is a mosh
pit of air molecules what's really going
on is as my voice tries to communicate
with you I'm squeezing air and that air
gets pulse towards your ear and you have
an eardrum on one side is just normal
pressure inside your head on the other
side is normal pressure in the room that
gives silence but when there is a
disturbance when the pressure is higher
your eardrum pushes in
when the pressure is lower your eardrum
pushes out because there's pressure on
the others so that fluctuation of the
eardrum is exactly what we hear as sound
so when you see a graph it's a graph of
the pressure it's not that sound is
going up and down
sound is being pushed towards you and
cold cold air is being pushed towards
employed okay so if you see people have
a misunderstanding of it there's nothing
going up and down what's going up and
down is the measure of the pressure okay
um so again what what do we hear let me
explain what that is supposed to
represent you get it so for a while
there was no sound all of a sudden there
was a big change in pressure and you're
here and then there is no change in
pressure again so that's one pump now if
we were to clap once per second so
that's called a 100 person Hertz it
would look like this join me don't rush
yeah so that's one percent the time
between each clap between each
fluctuation is called if the period one
over the period is the frequency how
many class per second and as we already
said that's one first now what if we
were two claps off what should the graph
look like
yeah it's exactly the same difference in
time but the amplitude is changing
cinema big amplitude a big change in
pressure it's a small change in pressure
we hear that is volume so amplitude is
volume gets measured in decibels which
is 1/10 of an Alexander Graham Bell
that's about all right what if we double
Prime okay that's 2 Hertz two beats per
second and the graph just has more
wiggles let's try this what if on one
hand you can do this on your knees maybe
on one hand you clap regular time on the
other hand you clap double time get it
what is the graph of that look like
there's it's big beep and then a little
beep right when both hands clap you got
a big beat and then when only one hand
got to get a little weak that is exactly
the sum of this picture and this picture
you see if this goes up a high one and
this also goes up a high one then the
sum of the two go up a height of two and
here is one plus zero point one okay so
everybody seen it so when you add two
sounds on top of each other that's the
superposition of sound waves just add
how about one two three
yeah not that how about two to three not
bad double you're getting it how about
43 stop somebody getting it let me give
you a little harder one four to seven
alright let's recap what can we
experience there Beatson is what we
experience what we hear is frequency is
how many beats a second and in platoon
is how strong is each fluctuation hell
out so amplitude is volume so we were to
sing this what would it sound like let's
try to destroy all together so we don't
change the notes the period is still the
same
we just think quietly that loud in five
days
yeah okay that's amplitude as a way
how about frequency frequency we hear is
pitch a fast frequency over here is a
high pitch and a low frequency over here
a slow wave yours alone hi-hi no we here
is a as a fast frequency so let's try to
sing this ready yeah so frequency is
pitch and amplitude is volume if we
speed up that little class that we were
doing not twice per second not three
times not 100 times
440 times the second what we would hear
is that's an a 440 the reed is
fluctuating 440 times a second and then
fluctuation is making its way to you
your brain interprets it as sound that's
an a what if we were doubling the
forwarding to double that frequency not
from 400 to 800 e you would hear just
one octave puckered okay so changes in
frequency corresponds to changes in the
note
what about Tambor what about quality of
sound how do we understand that yes
someone somebody said okay you're fine
if I play the same amplitude and the
same volume same amplitude on both those
they still sound different same
frequency same amplitude what's
different is the shape the quality the
sound is a turn by wave shape so you can
have a wave it looks like these
triangles these are feeds so you can
have a square wave or one of these
sinusoidal waves they sound different
even if they have the same frequency in
hand and how do you understand this
through calculus which I
not going to go into but it's worked out
at Joseph Fourier who showed that any
way whatsoever can actually be
decomposed as a superposition just as we
saw before a very simple pure wave so
you just have to use the right
frequencies and amplitudes let me let me
try to explain
so let's decompose this two on one side
and one on the other side let's
decompose that beat into pure wave so
these are waves are going around at 1
Hertz this is a sine wave barely
fluctuating at all very small amplitude
here's a tumor that's wiggling twice as
fast
there's a 3 Hertz and 4 Hertz so you see
the amplitudes are different and the
frequencies are integer multiples of the
original frequencies so this is wiggling
four beats a second and so on
there's the tenth contribution and if we
superimpose the ways we just add them on
top of each other when we go up to five
Hertz this is what the superposition
looks like I don't know if you can tell
the heartbeat underneath the
superposition and if we go out to ten
Hertz that's fourier spear the theorem
is you just make these very simple waves
and you add them up and you can get any
way you want and that is why you can
play rihanna on your ipod is because all
the computer can do computers can't
store complicated waves like they can
store numbers all the computer has to do
is store the frequency and the amplitude
of a bunch of numbers and then it can
make any shape of wave whatsoever so
let's solve our three mysteries here
they are again saxophone is the odd man
out the alto is the odd man out
lengthwise as far as the low note the
Sopranos the odd man out
tambour the clarinet is the weirdo so
let's answer the camera question the
sound again is determined by the
resident waves the clarinet is a
cylinder the length of the circle here
is almost exactly the same as the length
here it just looks like a strange
cylinder across everybody see that
whereas a saxophone looks like a cone it
starts out very very small and gradually
it's bigger never minded twists
gradually gets bigger and bigger so it
looks like a cone and so the
fluctuations the fact that this
declarant has a cylindrical bore means
it's overtone frequency doesn't have
even multiples if I over bloah you're
supposed to be if I play all of the
multiples of the original way so that's
the actual full overtone series now if I
don't change my fingers at all and I
just put more energy it's like jumping
from an s valence to T valence electron
you'll hear
it's skipping everybody note that it
should be play that's what you should be
here is instead what you're hearing and
that is just by changing how much
pressure it but how much power it book
through the point a saxophone has a
conical bore as we just said and that
allows you to overload all harmonics now
the winning isn't a simple sine wave
it's a little more complicated section
sine x over X but it allows all
frequencies to overblow and you should
hear okay okay
you heard almost all the harmonics I'm
sorry she's having a bad day but here's
the point is you're hearing the full
overtone series on a sax which you don't
hear on the clarinet so the answer to
question two why is the lowest note
different it's the same answer it's the
physics it's the mathematics of what
notes are the resonant waves going into
four eh theory and it's just the fact
from calculus that if you have a
cylindrical bore a bore that looks like
a cylinder air resonates at half at 3/4
the length your resonates the same
frequency as a cone which has three
times as long so three and three halves
times long so even though the alto is
quite a bit longer than the clarinet
they have the same lowest note whereas
the soprano as expected has a higher
lowest note because it's shorter than
the alto how about question one same
answer we just we just gave him the
lengths are different because that's
these are the frequencies going into the
one so all of the mysteries are solved
by understanding the resonant weight the
resonant frequency math explains
everything so let me give you three
homework problems here's some some
things to explain what's going on if we
pop it up
what's going on with that top here's
another phenomenon thunders game how
about won't be funny what's happening
there that was weird right
and the third one what happens
we've only been discussing single notes
but of course music is about not just
single notes music is about harmony
notes playing together
what's harmony but several voices
playing at once what's going on in you
here there let me give you a hint
remember when we were clapping two two
three
goodbye alright let's get back to the
Riemann hypothesis what what was the
Riemann hypothesis what Riemann actually
proved there's a mathematical theorem
that you prove and that theorem is
basically the analogue authorities
theorem you discovered some amazing wave
over time just four more minutes of your
time if that's okay these are some of
the ways that we month is covered and if
you look at their superposition if you
just add all these ways up you get
something that looks like this does that
look familiar
it's the we already saw this curve it
was the way that we got by subtracting
all s from the sum of the bomb angle
let's go back let's go back to the very
beginning from the very top to recall
the bomb angle function it has these log
values and it tells us which numbers are
prime or prime powers but there are very
few prime powers so the prime numbers
are the ones that are contributing the
most to that and we looked at its
partial sums and we saw a picture like
this and we immediately so the jumps
tell you where you find products on
friends house
and we immediately observe that there is
this the graph just looks like Y to the
x y y equals x right that we saw with
our eyes there it is is the fundamental
frequency of the trend it's the main
frequency it's the one that tells you
what the harming what the what note the
primes are playing but to get the full
characteristics it's the one that sounds
the loudest you get the full
characteristic you need the
superposition of all of harmonic waves
that's Riemann sphere so let's just have
this first wave remember this wave one
that I showed you
rimas weight one let's add it on top
everybody see what happened let's go
back we were there that's why it was X
we add it on top it's better
approximating that step function let's
add a second wave
here's way too on top of already added
wave one there it is how about going out
to wave tank you get that how about
going out to wave a hundred
Wow you see it's getting closer and
closer to exactly matching that step
clock so that's what Riemann proved that
there are these beautiful pure waves
just like if you're open for Ian's case
they're determined by two numbers
anyways key numbers once you numbers
putting the specify where you can see an
amplitude how fast a wiggle and how loud
to play and what Riemann did is plotted
the frequencies in the amplitude wave
zero that fundamental that y equals x
line has frequency zero it's not
wiggling at all and amplitude one it's
loud it's it's sounding the loudest of
all
all of the other ways they have some
frequencies which we don't know care you
can compute what these numbers are and
they have all of their amplitudes
playing at exactly volume 1/2 that 1/2
is the same 1/2 as the line y equals x
to the 1/2 that we saw in the randoms so
what do you think the Riemann hypothesis
States looking at this picture what do
you watch Yuri conjectures where do you
think wave limit is going to be over
here
over there over there over there yeah
they all the Riemann hypothesis says all
of the waves that add up play at exactly
the same volume there is a perfect
harmony this is the perfect structure of
the prime numbers all of the waves the
music that's making up the primes
there's this very clear line y equals x
and everything else is contributing much
much less and the amount is exchanging
by path that's the perfect structure and
Riemann sphere
alright let me just say I stole these
pictures from Wikipedia and Google
Images you should also check out this
wonderful book by Marcus de Soto I
called the music of the prize and
eventually I'll throw some of these
pictures and computer programs on my
websites you can download